certain extent web 3.0 is back to the
future when we started looking at a lot
of the value that was accumulating
around the internet was around user
contributed content service but what the
users were creating now again too many
of us the what academics were doing the
original early in the early internet was
sharing our papers which is you know
we're sharing our content that's what we
do we write papers and do research and
we were using it we were the suppliers
of all of the service and then big
service providers get along to provide
news and other things but there was
realized that a lot of the content was
arising from the individuals right there
but at this point it was now getting
aggregated into these large platforms
and so when three arises as a reaction
to that and in one way to say it is Back
to the Future it's how do we form any of
these systems take back control so there
are many variants of this there's
obviously Tim berners-lee himself
talking about his work at MIT and solid
and that's one vision it's a line of
research that we've been pursuing for
some number of years and in a previous
video more talked about some of the
principles of human data interaction
which is sort of a three reticle
framework we're looking at but the
instantiation of that the really a thing
called data box we don't need to know
your shopping history we just need to
know whether you are a big spender
meaning of spender or title
that's maybe not that all we care about
but I think we need to look at why the
data box so a lot of the concerns around
web 3 is people are monetizing the data
that we're giving them and we're not
getting fair value and that's one
concern I think you know each Facebook
user is a circular be worth thirty five
dollars to Facebook in terms of
advertising revenue essentially and
people are going what can I get my fair
share of that one it's like well what's
your fair share of $35 you know it's
gonna change your life right so I have
an individual level the
the data I find as an economic incentive
a bit spurious those who make
substantial money on the internet by
being influencers it can be paid for it
they will continue to do that and by
their very nature they're essentially
producing curated content and they're
getting paid for it and that's fine it's
not their personal data that's getting
monetized so I'm always slightly dubious
with the economic argument about this
and I actually come at it from a lot a
different set of angles and one of the
first and foremost one is privacy and
actually we just start with the law you
don't have to get into ethical debates
the law and data protection regulation
being the most recent in Europe these
are the bases on which data to be
processed so on take an example if I
have a fancy new Internet of Things like
switch in my house to control a fancy
new Internet of Things bulb then you
would think that while they both talked
the Internet Protocol which is what I
want them to do why on earth do any of
these packets need to leave my home
that's the simple question why do they
need to leave my home and the answer of
course is they don't now if I won't be
able to switch my light on from remotely
from out on my mobile phone when I'm out
in a byte then then the question is how
does my mobile phone send IP packets to
that well it looks like an ordinary
light switch
which goes to the right play web page
turn the lights on and off indeed a box
we take the views while you might want
to have a server that keep looking at
that theater I don't get to why in a
minute
then it should be in your house and that
there is no need for the data to go
beyond that and then under data
protection law we were supposed to
privacy by design and by default and
that means that I my view is that if
that means you can build the thing
without sharing the data then hmm I
think the law says you're supposed to do
that now at this point those big
companies will say we'll get your
consent to share the data because
actually we need we want the data for
all the purposes so the fact that they
can get when light switches switch on
and off well what can that tell them
well I can tell them when you're at home
start telling them which room you're in
especially they start doing currently
across devices so we start getting into
inferences about people people will be
murid about this with their online web
habits and shopping habits this is
nothing compared to being able to know
every time you could let toilet or
something and it's unclear what
companies will try to do with that data
so I would just start off by saying they
don't need it there's it's not like
you're gonna get paid a lot of money for
this so why don't we just build
architectures in the future to keep this
data in the home where we can so on that
there's a fundamental privacy argument
there the second one again comes about
due to the law I am entitled to take all
my personal data and process it however
I see fit well as a company it actually
can find itself getting into
difficulties if it has too much personal
data it gets itself into a regulatory
morass so any company that holds that
being ages and financial transactions
has to not just comply with data
protection laws they have to apply
comply with financial services laws as
well so imagine a company that tries to
hold all your data it's got a regulatory
nightmare of what it can and can't do
with that data
so I actually invade a box we view this
as a place as where if the data exists
online you can pull that data end so you
can bring it down through the API server
available it's generated in the home
from from our ot devices or you type it
in you know you give it the data has
access to your calendar and your address
book and all the bits and pieces Anakin
can you hear with your phone then it can
start to mash up data from different
sources imagine I could take where my
phone is the readings from the PIR
sensors but it's all passive infrared
sensors that many people have in their
arms as part of the burglar alarm system
lighting controls heating controls any
controls are nice and start to
understand and build a model of that
user in that house within the date
within the data box within the heights
privately a private model and someone
might say well if we could process that
data it's very important here they
figured process that data
then we might be able to provide you
with some value so say for example
someone could supply an application that
would run on the data box which would be
a burglar alarm application which is
right we'll take your PIR sensors and
everything else burglars will do around
the house and not switch the lights on
and so we can build a really smart
burglar alarm that could really
understand what's going on yeah
it's probably going to get me going to
the toilet in the night solidly well you
know it's actually are they downstairs
we won't go around but then the flip
side of that is exactly all the same
theater assets could be used for an
elderly care out today people are
thinking of Internet of Things services
with a Clyde at the center of the device
in the home and they limit themselves to
the functionality that uses a reasonable
amount of bandwidth because they can't
absorb all the bandwidth on the internet
connection out of the home they often
assume far too much IFA one device that
does a TCP connection every second it
just sits there and polling the cloud
service to see if it's I should say it's
on a separate network which I know I
prevented accessing the internet but it
tries to do that and actually it doing
that on my local area network I don't
care because it's not a problem but if
those if all those connections were
going up and down over my broadband link
it's like I may use devices before I
start in such impacting my life and
that's pretty trivial example so people
are limiting what they imagine IOT
devices can do in the home because of
the but not used too much bandwidth but
on the other hand taking video from
multiple cameras processing it in a
daily box which could be a Raspberry Pi
doing this it's not talking about it
high-end computer could provide new
functionalities that people are
currently not thinking about so there's
that as well and finally when it comes
to looking after home I'd like my light
switches to work when the Internet's
dying I'd certainly want my birdly or
Antwerp in the Internet Stein because
the first thing burglars hit is the
power and the telecommunications going
out of the light so I really would like
it not to rely on a cloud service for
all sorts of reasons and more so when we
get into these
applications for looking after the
younger in their homes so let's relate
this back to this web free movement
I think web 3 is about you know getting
control back of your data and
understanding how to process it for your
own value and publishing what you want
to publish and is a good example where
the raw data that I have I might whatnot
want to publish but I might be quite
happy to publish some statistical data
that's derived from it so you know for
advertising purposes if someone wants to
know whether you should advertise to me
you know tea or something yeah then I'd
be perfectly happy if they supplied an
app which used my electricity monitoring
to notice how many times I bought the
kettle in the day but what I don't want
to do is share the data of what time of
day and how long I bought it for and
everything else but I'll happily share
that on average I have four cups of tea
a day I mean that's not really a
concerning personal statistic but
sharing exactly when the kettle got
switched on and off every day publicly
with possibly others could get hold of
it that then gives an occupancy pattern
to the household so the day that can be
reused for purposes that it wasn't
intended for and that's I think where a
lot of the uneasiness around the data in
the world is at the moment is that we're
giving them we engage in these
transactions and sometimes we hand over
data and all of the data gets monitored
as we use a website all sorts of things
are monitored just as we move around the
website and while we have to share some
data to get the job done it's got the
point where we no longer of any idea
what the data is being used for and it's
not clear it's being used to our benefit
and so we really want to get control of
that but as I said I don't quite believe
the economic argument of my data will
suddenly be worth I can't believe off my
data I might get a few beers out of my
data only but I might rather open up
much greater value in this data
ecosystem by completely transforming it
to be
of this Web 3 model of applications you
know send the code to my data I might
share some statistics from you but
actually it may just be your code
running on my data and that's the
transaction I get something I want and I
pay you money for that and it's a
product remember those things products
with what we just had services
everything to service we have all sorts
of more of those apps on this right all
sorts of crazy things that are really
useful to us and they are remotely
managed and they're remotely updated and
all of the problems that people talked
about oh you couldn't possibly run your
own email service at home it's like well
no because the usual way of running it
is become the Linux systems guru and
start from there right whereas in fact
if any of these companies applied their
knowledge and experience to you know
actually providing privacy-preserving
solutions in the home they can do it and
they could make it just as easy to use
we have now moved to a world where we
can support very complex technologies
you know whatsapp for example is one of
the world's most complex crypto
protocols you can imagine whatsapp
signal in Akko have decided this is a
bit of a problem do you know that do you
care no it just works right because all
of the complexity of the double ratchet
element all the way in which it does
privacy protection you didn't have to
engage in it you didn't have a system
administrator you didn't have to
generate public keys it was all just
done and the bringing of the the
automation and the the danger that the
digital has given us to provide these
technologies No
and so web 3.0 is exactly that there's
the argument that we can all just run an
Xbox at home it's like yes we could but
we would all have to become a Linux box
experts but actually there's no reason
why we can't do what we do with the
phone apps today which is remotely
support them and have all of this great
technology and our own homes and
actually providing new functionality
take social media well actually most
people they want to do social
interaction you want to talk to you like
30 or 40 minutes and find out what they
do again that doesn't require the
publishing of things on walls so we've
seen that even within the Facebook
family of people moving from Facebook to
whatsapp for a lot more of the
discussions or snapchat and these other
more things where by default you're
talking a small
social group and supporting those sorts
of technologies between in a web three
way by building a peer-to-peer network
you know well actually we did do that
quite a number of years ago and it was
called Skype so we had it and then it
got acquired by Microsoft and turned
back into a centralized service now if
you're truly paranoid at this point you
would identify that of course at the
point that they did that they also
allied government agencies to get access
to it as well so for the truly paranoid
out there one of the reasons and lots of
people have advocated moving to a
peer-to-peer network it's for those who
are very worried about you know state
surveillance so we don't need to know
your shopping history we just need to
know whether you are a big spender
Amedeo spender or maybe that's all we
care about and this is not how they're
going to do it the next thing we could
do is we could say well why can't we use
the same kind of protocol to establish
keys